soir anthony bonsoir très bon dos et on
va revenir sur ce naufrage du croiseur
russe moskva il a sombré ce jeudi soir
en mer noire et avant même son naufrage
des publications photos à l'appui évoqué
son explosion on met une photo en
particulier on va la découvrir ensemble
qui a beaucoup circulé alors avant mais
également après désir sera après le
naufrage que voit-on une explosion assez
floue vu de loin et le verre de l image
donne un côté un peu militaire comme si
c'était une image de ralliant de
renseignement de nuit prises de nuit
effectivement alors cette image on la
retrouve par exemple sur ce compte
twitter le 14 avril au matin et qui nous
dit quoi qui nous dit que c'est bien la
photo de l' incendie du moskva clichés
repris aussi par cet utilisateur du
facebook de facebook qui lui va ironisé
sur la version donnée par moscou qui
jeudi matin on reconnaissait bien que le
bâtiment avait été endommagé et qui par
la suite a reconnu la perte en du mauss
g et qu'il attribue à une explosion d'un
stock de munitions là où kiev évoque des
frappes ukrainienne mais cette image que
vous nous montrez n'est pas celle du
muscle a effectivement on est bien en
mer noire on va y revenir je vous laisse
un petit peu marine et une photo hors
contexte donc mais également trafic et à
deux niveaux regarder le filtre vert
d'abord qui n'est pas d'origine et puis
l'image a été retournée on va regarder
ensemble l'original la voix si c'est
donc dès lorsque vous les mettez côte à
côte ce que l'on va faire et bien vous
avez plusieurs éléments ici par exemple
le bateau que l'on voit ici ou encore
noté la forme un peu en escalier
finalement delà de la fumée vous le
retrouvez sur effectivement cette autre
image donc l'image virale la forme en
escalier ici et le bateau le bâtiment en
question inversez donc comme je disais
ces modifications elles sont très
simples à faire elles peuvent
s'effectuer tout bêtement via un
logiciel de retouche photo c'est
d'ailleurs ce qu'a rappelé 1 un
internaute sur twitter via une vidéo
vous voyez une démonstration en six
secondes top chrono maintenant d'où
vient cette photo maintenant que je vous
ai fait mariner le fait qu'elles aient
été trafiqués va forcément compliqué la
recherche d'image inversée lorsque vous
vous rendez sur yandex le moteur de
recherche russe vous trouvez après c'est
pas immédiats info plusieurs recherches
vous trouvez plusieurs occurrences on
voit par exemple ici la même photo ou
encore ici et à chaque fois ça nous
renvoie ou sur un reportage de
consacrer à deux navires tanzanien qui
ont pris feu en mer noire c'est vrai on
est en janvier 2019 et plus d'une
dizaine de personnes ont alors péri dans
cet incident au train fox toujours lié
au croiseur russe que cette fois ci
c'est une vidéo effectivement à
plusieurs publications vont présenter
cette vidéo comme l'explosion du navire
on a par exemple ce twittos qui nous dit
voici le moment où le croiseur de moscou
de son nom reçoit les salutations de
l'armée ukrainienne on notera évidemment
le petit brin d'humour d'humour noir
évidemment il ya cette vidéo d'une
frappe sur le navire russe mosca donc et
ce tweet aux sept autres twittos de
données même l'origine de la publication
andrei bill est ce qui figure historique
du bataillon azoff pour en être
évidemment le fondateur effectivement
cette vidéo vous la retrouvez ici sur le
conte télégramme officiel d'andrei
habilite ski petite parenthèse sur azoff
un groupe paramilitaire on le sait est
incorporé à l'armée régulière dans la
garde nationale ukrainienne et dont
certains de ses membres se soutiennent
clairement l'idéologie nazie voilà pour
la parenthèse alors le fondateur d'azov
a effectivement lié cette courte vidéo à
l'actualité liée aux au croiseur russe
là où en fait la recherche d'image
inversée nous renvoie une vidéo beaucoup
plus longues sur youtube vous voyez à la
date on naît le 6 juin 2013 vous voyez
aussi cette ses initiales swn s c'est
une chaîne à britannique une agence
britannique plus précisément south west
news service il s'agit en fait d'un tir
de missile d'un test plus exactement
domicile de la marine norvégienne ondes
et donc le 6 juin 2013 deux exemples ce
soir qui montre qu'une fois de plus
comme on l'a répété ces dernières
semaines que cette guerre en ukraine
menée par la russie elle se fait aussi
sur le font de la désinformation et on
voit tantôt du côté russe tantôt du côté
ukrainien merci beaucoup anthony st
léger merci à vous d'avoir suivi cette
demi heure d'information se retrouve
tout de suite pour un nouveau journal
après cette courte pause